transportation in America is an utter
wreck literally but mayor Pete is more
focused on his ridiculous Progressive
priorities like how our roads are racist
the transportation secretary once again
trying to satisfy the woke when asked
about car accidents
there are a lot of reasons related to
discrimination related to the even the
ways that roads are designed and built
who has access to a safe Street design
that's got crosswalks and good lighting
who doesn't have that access that can
drive disparities and we have a
responsibility to act on that
you know Greg I I I'm not even going to
ask about whether roads can be racist
I'm going to say that for the next
person but given the fact that Buddha
Jets struggled with black voters in
2020. the question is is this his way of
trying to win them over and as
Transportation secretary do you think
he's done anything on this it has to be
that has to be the reason because look
the this assumption can only be taken
seriously if you if you work with like
one variable which is what the left
often does and so their variable is
always going to be race the thing the
reason why there are all these accidents
and fatalities has got to be race there
was a study I I wrote about it a while
ago a couple years ago where they
compared um blacks were pulled over more
at much higher rates in America than
Asians for speeding they were getting
speeding tickets and it turned out that
what was called racist was actually
there are more young black drivers in
America than there are Asian drivers
young people drive faster getting most
accidents often why they have the
highest insurance premiums but if you
just ignore that one variable of age
there are more younger blacks than there
are younger other groups and guess who's
careless in cars young people as for
Road access and lighting I mean I don't
know like there's a chicken and egg
thing going on here when you talk about
the food deserts like you know the food
deserts that's why that's why minorities
don't get a look at their nutrition and
then you see looting and then that's
like wow
why is whose fault is this you know what
I mean those stores don't want to be in
neighborhoods anymore where they where
people are getting treated like in San
Francisco Dana why is Pete focused on
this I mean with all the train
derailments and all the problems at the
airports and everything else why this
well I think one of the things that we
sort of forget is that mayor Pete is not
on an island mayor Pete is part of a
cabinet who reports to President Biden
and this is a President Biden priority
so this is being driven from the White
House and who's in charge of Department
of Transportation at the White House
Susan Rice who runs a domestic policy
Council so this is a priority for them
and that's fine you can list your
priorities what I think is interesting
is that you don't also have then the
Secretary of Education coming out with
an absolute bullhorn to complain that
every Urban School District does not
have children who can read and do math
at grade level and they pass them on
anyway and so why do you have this
problem it's like the broken windows
theories of street lights or crosswalks
of what these things aren't working
whose fault is that and local
governments are to be responsible for
that but they get a lot of federal money
so part of this is okay then mayor Pete
White House Mr President What
specifically are you going to do about
it what is the targeted answer for any
of this but I get back to the issue of
Education I cannot believe that that is
not considered the number one five alarm
fire for this Administration and anybody
who's running for president right now
well what about car accidents that
happen in other parts of the world I
mean in other countries would he say
that they're racist as well that's a
great question let's broaden the sample
size let's broaden the pool you know
judge I thought I wanted to come into
this segment and just have a good time
about the idea of racist roads but I'll
actually want to say something else I
want to say this racism is real like
it's it's a statement that I think
perhaps a lot of us who rightfully point
to reason don't perhaps make enough
racism is a real issue in the United
States of America but I believe that
idea is undercut more by people who
attempt to explain every disparate
impact by one single variable as you
point out and less by people that deny
the existence of racism if you water
down a concept to its absurdity to
racist roads you have lost a willing
listener you've lost people willing to
understand racism is a problem it's an
interpersonal problem I believe an
individual problem and you have lost the
ability to win people through reason and
persuasion through this stupidity that's
a great point and and what do you think
Jessica about this I think that it's
more complicated than just one variable
of course but it's a real variable that
he's talking about and the history of it
so this goes back to the National
highways Act of 1956 and when there were
changes in zoning laws because finally
we came around to the idea that blacks
and whites should be able to live
together what the government did is they
built highways through the middle of
major cities to ended up destroying them
so like I understate 375 cuts through
Detroit and there are a number of black
communities that are essentially cut off
just out in the abyss there on the other
side of the highway without access to
the same kinds of things that whites
have access to we talked about this as
well the uh the difference in outcomes
for black communities or communities of
color versus whites when it comes to
pollution there was a huge study in 2021
about the air quality in communities of
color and blacks worse than other
minority groups and certainly worse than
whites suffered from air pollution due
to construction that's done in the
places that they live in these
communities I'm curious because I always
hear I've heard that that's not that's
not important okay that's okay
because we always we're told how bad it
was as if it never gets better 1954 is
how many years 70 years ago 60 70 years
ago and we always have to go back we're
always looking backwards we always act
like the sins of the 50s or the sins now
why have it why hasn't your party
improved this why why is he talking
about it now well what city is this
happening in is is it a democratic City
what if you your party done instead of
lecturing us on language or or taking
800 million dollars at what's meant for
the homeless and making it disappear
what are you doing
rather than telling everybody that we're
racist first of all I did not say that I
know I meant you generally but don't
because me is the only person sitting
here and I I took Extra Care to make
sure to make this point in a thoughtful
way that did not fall into the Trap of
this is just racism but to talk about
the fact that there are systemic
challenges to black people in this
country that whites do not face because
of where they live because of the
actions that our government took so what
have Democratic Representatives done for
people suffering from this well they
were the ones that actually got the
Flint whiter Water Crisis paid attention
to it took too long but that was all
Democrats fighting Flint not a big deal
huge deal there I mean kids are drinking
lead infested water what's a bigger deal
than that
there are parts of Rural America too
where people don't and I sat here when
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now